-It is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go!
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet"!
This is where we,
as a group, decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote
on whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You find them there?
Yeah.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want,
and we're going to see
the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you guys have your clickers?
-Got it.
-That's good.
Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will all tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
at home and "wetweet" it.
-Ahhhhhh.
-It's like a shared experience.
Are you guys ready for this?
[ Cheering ]
Are you ready for this?!
[ Cheering loudly ]
All right, the first tweet is...
"James Thomas Fallon!
Get in here!"
-I'm gonna say yes.
-"Finish the job!"
[ Laughter ]
All right, let's see.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results on this.
Okay.
All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Very honest --
very honest audience.
Yeah, they didn't necessarily --
-Like, body temperature, 98.
-Didn't necessarily love it.
-No, didn't hate it.
-Didn't hate it, either.
-But just didn't care for it.
-They're just lukewarm.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It's all right.
-"That's a tweet, sure."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Let's try this next one.
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know, honey.
I don't think we can afford it.
I think we go
with the backyard first
and don't worry
about the countertops.
I don't think we --"
-"What?"
-"I'm not even gonna
buy this house.
You know how expensive
that thing is gonna be?
That's like $300.
There's no way
I'm buying it, ever."
We'll take it.
We'll take the house."
-"We're digging house
number two."
-All right.
I feel better about this one.
-I feel really good.
-Let's see the results on this.
-Yeah! All right.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I felt good about that one.
Let's try this next one here.
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
-"What? Oops!"
-"Oh, someone's
getting a new bikini."
[ Laughter ]
Let's see the results here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-Not as much.
-Wow. No, they didn't care
for that one.
-No, they liked it.
-Well, liked it, but not much.
-This one feels pretty good.
-The next one feels good.
-I like the other one.
The renovation was good.
-Yeah, that was good.
-Yeah, but I think this
next one...
-You think this next one.
-They don't necessarily
get better is the sad thing.
-No.
-And you didn't make a
"telescope looking at Uranus"
joke, which was good.
[ Laughter ]
I'm proud of you.
-Not my type of humor.
-I know. I'm proud of you
for doing that.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Next up...
[ Laughter ]
-"Let's go, kids. Come on.
Come on!"
-That's it.
"I don't know where to start.
I don't know where to start.
Let's just get a --"
"You don't have
granite countertops, do you?
If we didn't have granite,
wouldn't have broken
the olive oil."
All right.
I think this is gonna be --
Everyone voted?
All right,
let's see the results.
There you go.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
-That's really good.
-Got some winners.
-Yeah, that was good.
This last one's good, too,
but I think that one's
going to be the winner.
But this last one is funny, too.
All right, here we go.
This last one says...
[ Laughter ]
"Just stay seated."
-Come on!
"We're eventually
all gonna get off the plane!
Trust me, no one's
ever just forgotten about us."
-"Where are they?!
We forgot them!"
-"They forgot to open the --"
No, that's never happened.
We're all gonna leave
eventually.
All right, let's see
the results on this one here.
Bam!
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
All right.
We got a winner right there.
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a wetweet, and enjoy.